so everybody's turning up to see the
periodic videos first birthday
celebration and in true chemistry
fashion we'd forgot our knives so we're
going to have to find a chemistry way of
dividing the cake let's see if this
works
and you can see there it feels like cake
it certainly got the sponginess they'll
smell this from the other side of the
building and they'll want to eat this
but they just can't because you made it
in the lab there are loads of our
chemicals around loads of bits and
pieces kicking about you don't know you
know who else has used all the glassware
and the metal ware and everything you
know why everyone yeah
happy birthday is it well that's tasty
so here we've got a table and we're
going to dress that cake for our party
so we're going to put it on a nice layer
of cotton wool because it makes it look
nice we're really using that to reduce
its density and hopefully get lots of
oxygen in there a little bit later than
there's a cake before Neal adds the
fantastic liquid oxygen that he made a
little bit earlier on who does you know
know that's my favorite we thought it's
a chemist chemistry cakes it probably
gonna be slightly sour and a little bit
nasty to taste so we thought we'd add
some sugar some icing sugar so here's
the icing sugar on the top it's got a
little bit of a chemical additive that
we've
just to see if we can increase the
sparkle in the color of our cake so
there's Neil adding that fantastic
liquid oxygen some of you have seen this
device before we used it with the liquid
oxygen video it's called a match on a
stick for today's party we've modified
the match on a stick the traditional
match on a stick design and we've added
a stunt cam and you can see the stunt
cam here so let's turn the camera on
okay oh yeah it's recording let's see if
this works
anyway you ready met whoo the cake is
indestructible
dr. tangs cake survives liquid oxygen
next stop thermite most unexpected and
like a real experiment you can never
predict the result what are you doing
we're trying to saturate dr. tangs
biscuit with a little bit more liquid
oxygen so you can see it all boiling
away there enriching the oxygen
atmosphere so breathe in we have the
oxygen soaked biscuit yeah okay so let's
try again
oh it's burnin
ah
anybody for a piece of cake